yes it's that time of year again and for
number files that means one thing
advent calendars for each day of
december i'm going to be adding a new
video link to each number in the
calendar on december 1 number 1 december
2 number 2 and so on it could be a
number file video old on you it could be
one of my other videos from another
channel or from another youtuber
altogether but the one thing they'll
have in common either in an obvious or
non-obvious way is an association with
the number one of the videos is also
going to be an unlisted one that you'll
only be able to watch through the advent
calendar because i'm a bit sneaky like
that i know that annotations don't work
for some people so there are also links
under the video so please come back each
day of december or whenever you choose
and find out what videos have been added
and also it's not too late to suggest
one if there's one you think i should be
linking to
well if you're still here i'm going to
tell you you should also be following
numberphile on twitter or facebook
links below
[Music]
all right you've had long enough now if
you haven't clicked on something by now
you're never going to click so i'm
stopping the video